estamos en la universidad del valle aquí
en cali donde está la mina indígena con
más de 5000 personas en la tarde del
domingo hubo un grave enfrentamiento en
la ciudad de cali cuando la mina trataba
de regresar a la universidad del valle
se encontraron con una manifestación que
les impidió el paso y terminaron civiles
armados de esperando contra la minga
esto dejó varios heridos a destacar que
vecinos del sector y policías también
denunciaron que parte de la minga trató
de banalizar edificios y vehículos esto
se produce después de que vecinos de
esos sectores más acomodados de la
ciudad de cali estén denunciando que hay
peajes ilegales y saqueos que nada
tendrían que ver con la protesta el
presidente iván duque estuvo unas horas
en la pasada noche aquí en la ciudad de
cali en un consejo de seguridad y ha
pedido a los indígenas que vuelvan a sus
resguardos algo que desde la minga han
dicho que es necesario producirá cuando
el presidente se reúna con ellos y
además han continuado han dicho que
continuarán marchando de forma pacífica
como hasta ahora hablamos con algunos de
sus líderes
nosotros estamos abiertos al diálogo a
poner nuestras posturas sobre la mesa en
el debate pero el presidente dice que no
nos atiende acá en halle primero decir
que la minga siempre ha sido itinerante
y que se ha desplazado a diferentes
puntos del país por eso no compartimos
la invitación del presidente duque
volver a los territorios